-Sup gang?
Episode 25.
Ask, oh no not Ask Gary.
Keep it DRock you know
I like it, DailyVee.
(honking and thumping music)
How are you?
- I'm doing well.
-Good.
What episode is
this going to be?
- [DRock] 25.
- DailyVee 25 but DRock
we've only put out what 22.
Where's 23?
- [DRock] It's South By.
- When is it coming?
Hey sis.
All good.
Do you have Snapchat yet?
You have to really watch it.
That's where all
the good stuff is.
Whatever works.
Sup man?
You have been around the
world and back 4000 times
in the last 36 hours.
I sure have.
How the hell are
you here right now?
That's how I roll.
Even to Mars.
You've been to Mars.
It's true Greg I've
been to Mars and back.
Sup And?
This is it, this is the game.
You can see where I'm at right
now right and I think we need
to go tighter and
deeper on what works.
Staph, I think when an episode
of DailyVee goes up you need to
read the comments the next
morning on Facebook and YouTube.
Inevitably, people are
going to be talking about
their favorite parts.
Good to be home in
New York temporarily.
Happy birthday, DRock.
How old are you?
- [DRock] 25.
- 25 and this
might be episode 25.
It's very meta.
Might be 24.
I can't remember.
Actually don't you know.
What did we just put out? 22?
- [DRock] Figure out if
WeWork is an episode or not.
Cause WeWork and
then private jet.
I don't know if that's one.
- I think it is because the
stuff I talked about in there.
- [DRock] Then that's 24.
London's 25.
- No, Australia's 25.
- [DRock] Oh yeah.
- Got it so that's...
- [DRock] If we didn't do
WeWork and private jet,
that brings it back.
- So why don't we do WeWork as
a separate piece of content?
Put it up. Okay.
So do that so this is 25 then.
'Cause I like it being
25 on your birthday.
Right, so one more
time, South-by is 23.
Australia's 24.
Okay. And then this is 25.
So you can have Staphon
start putting up WeWork as
a separate piece of content.
I think we should
just put that out.
- [DRock] Yes.
- Cool.
- [DRock] Really good
advice in that.
- Was a really good talk.
- [DRock] That'll crush.
- Yeah, I think that's
just a good keynote.
WeWork keynote in Boston
with the date and that's it.
- [DRock] So you want to
resume the whole vlog?
- What's that?
No, I just want to
keep it as it just was.
I think it's cool that
are ready just see how
we just figured out.
Why you always
trying to edit DRock?
Lizzie gets shit done.
India can get it done.
All right, what else
while I'm sitting here?
- [Matt] The dinner, the dinners--
- Yeah those kind
of that concept.
- [Matt] Yep, I have dates.
25th of April.
I think one in April is--
- That's it, that's it.
- [Matt] Okay.
First one in April--
- Isn't there date already place
some of these guys?
VaynerMedia you saw that little
email, 70, 80 we got to get much
more Vayner which is why I
moved my podcast, that's Gary.
VaynerMedia needs to take flight
I just need to grow the business
a little bit more.
So those are two VaynerMedia
that's two VaynerMedia
things, right?
- [Man] Yes.
Yeah.
It's a net-net game.
Show me.
- [Trouty] And six months later
if it's not working,
- [Gary] It's steps. It's clearly steps.
None the shit happens overnight.
I think we have we have a
good enough relationship.
We're building relationship
within the building as a
holistic thing and I know what
our best work is and you know
it's really crazy in a B2B
environment it stunning how okay
I am if none of this
ever happens because
I just know life.
I'm just practical.
I know I don't get
to make the call.
But what I don't want to do is
ever waiver for what is good for
our top line revenue.
I think the reason why I'm going
to build one of these companies
is I want to do is
what's going to sell beer.
I just care about business.
By the way, real quick I
just want to know why.
I'm only building this for it
to be the backbone of my own
private equity
activity for my whole life.
I don't need your money.
I need to know if it works so
that I can got out and
buy you know the
IP to Zima one day.
- [Axel] Gary Vee.
- Hello.
- How are you, sir?
- Axel.
- Such a pleasure.
- Same here.
- I'm John.
- John, how are you?
- It's very, very rare when you
see somebody like yourself that
is just from the heart and just
giving and giving and giving and
giving which is something that
me and him are similar as far as
I we are where
giving and giving.
Even with failures, dude.
We've fucking have been
failing like crazy for
the past two years, man.
- I think for you guys and
anybody just this conversation
you have to figure out what
you're good at because that's
the only thing you
should be doing.
- [Axel] Okay.
- If you can figure out what
you're good at that the only
thing you should be doing.
- [Axel] Right.
- That's the key.
The reason so many people are
doing the wrong thing, mentors
masterminds, bull shit is 'cause
they're not good enough to win
the right way.
- [Axel] Okay.
- Anybody that can win the
right way is going to
win the right way.
- [Axel] Right.
- Guys, there's an entire world
that has no idea who these
bullshit people are on
Instagram, Internet marketers
and masterminds. It's called
everybody else I know.
Right.
If you're good enough
to make money by doing
that you do that,
you do that.
- [Axel] Exactly.
It's a people are
doing short-term.
- [Axel] Short-term gain.
Not talented enough so they're
just want to sell people.
- [Axel] Right.
If you going to sell information
you can only sell what you know.
- [Axel] Right.
The problem with everybody
selling information is
what you sell me? How to
make $1 million?
What are you going to sell
me to make a great life?
- [Axel] Exactly.
What? Are you going to sell me
on being an entrepreneur?
They're all full of shit.
So what?
Sell me how to
read a book everyday?
What are you going to sell me?
Nothing that's true.
You can only sell what's true.
And do I think people will
pay 100 bucks a month to sit on
Google stream and you be there
psychologist, psychiatrist,
listening ear and you just tell
your real life stories
how you found each other?
You could tell me how to
have long-distance friendships.
You can only sell the truth.
- [Axel] Understand.
- So what I would do is
reverse engineer what
you guys are about.
You know?
You can sell only on being young
brown men in America because
there's a lot of shit
going on with that.
- [Axel] Right.
That I don't know that may be
really helpful. I don't know.
But you can only
sell me what's true.
That's the game.
- [Axel] Right.
Not posing as
something you're not.
- [Axel] Right.
So you might only make $31,000 a
year because people are only
willing to spend $100 a month
to get that advice because
it is not a very big market.
It's a much bigger market,
"I'm going to make you
seven fuckin' figures passive."
Everybody falls for that.
But then you build something.
I make the least money out of my
expertise out of anybody online.
- [Axel] Right.
- There's no mastermind.
There's no funnel.
DailyVee doesn't start and then
you have to pay $4.99 a week.
- [Axel] Exactly.
And then once in a
fuckin' blue moon
a.k.a. every three fucking
years I ask for $18.
Not a good business model.
I'm going to start firing people
for not filling out brackets.
Then people will start
fuckin' paying attention.
- [Man] I don't get it.
It took me 30 seconds.
- It's serious around here.
Gabe if these guys are new
you've been here fuckin'--
- Listen, man I got the rest of
the team to fill theirs out
but between brain decoder between--
- Are you really in
the excuse business?
- I'm not an excuse business.
- Really?
As such a winner, you're such
a winner and you decide
to go excuse on me.
You're right you're 100% right.
Thank you.
No excuse.
- [Gary] So wait a minute today
is the first day of the
tournament and St. Patty's day?
- [Gabe] Yeah.
- What a killer day for bars
or they might be upset.
They might have bastardized
the two days.
They might have lost a day.
- [Gabe] Lost revenue.
- They get like 80% of it.
That happens a lot.
- Yeah.
- I always like when Christmas
Eve falls on different days
not on Thursday, Friday or
Saturday for Wine Library.
Were trying to get through
the St. Patty's day parade.
(marching band songs)
Do you know about my daily vlog?
- [Woman] No.
- Well I'm very upset.
- [Woman] That's why I'm
out of the shot because
I didn't do my hair today.
- Hey, look at you!
- How are you?
- Congratulations on the book.
- Thank you.
- How are you?
- You're thinner?
- Yeah, I am thinner.
(fast paced ambient music)
Cool.
Hey dude.
Signature here.
No, with who?
I'm sorry Jess it
chopped for a second.
And then on this one
here you going to write
to whom it may concern.
- [Lauryn] You guys don't
normally do five
people at a time?
[Gary &amp; DRock] No.
But we'll figure it out.
You guys ready?
Are you my primary?
- [DRock] Yes, I am the primary.
- Rad.
It's DRock's birthday.
- [Michael] I know.
We just heard.
Not there's a podcast kinda
going Barbara Walters.
- 191?
- [Staphon] Yep.
- Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 191
of the #AskGaryVee show.
- Two silent E's.
- It was so much fun.
You did such a great job.
You guys killed it.
Congratulations I'm
so happy for you guys.
- I'll be back because I
want you to be on my channel.
Done.
- Thank you.
You did a great job.
Thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
Brother, continued success.
- Ok. Thanks man.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, good luck.
I need power.
Hello.
- [Woman] Hello.
- Hello.
- [Man] Hello.
I'm sorry I'm late.
- No, hi I'm Kelly.
- Kelly, Gary.
- Hi, I'm Lauren.
- Lauren.
- Yeah, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
The new bookscan numbers.
- [Andy] I know.
Did you see that?
- [Andy] It's insane.
The next one closest--
- [DRock] It's not even close.
- [Matt] What is this?
That's how many books
sold this week on bookscan.
- Look at one to compared to two.
- I want you to add all them up.
I actually think I sold more
every other book combined
on the list. Like all of them.
That's insane.
- Hello.
- Hey, nice to meet
you I'm Carolyn.
- Carolyn, Gary.
How are you?
- Hi, David.
- Andy.
- Alright, let's go.
- Let's go.
I'm Andy today.
What you want to do
on YouTube, Andy?
- Have you been vlogging?
- Yes.
- Are you vlogging?
- I am. I'm here.
Hey guys I'm here.
Yes.
Just kinda I would be lying if I
didn't say I was excited to hear
that that's kind of where your
opening line went because it
does speak to building
bigger businesses and
things of that nature.
I'm just excited about it while
recognizing maybe that the first
task at hand does go down just
the sales performance angle.
(relaxed ambient music)
Is there anything you want to
add Richard or is a good kind of
starting point to contextualize
because I definitely feel like I
have a grasp on what
you guys are focused on.
Sup gang?
Episode 25 ask oh
no not ask Gary.
Keep it DRock, you know
how I like it, DailyVee.
Kind of feeling like I'm trying
to find new ways to bring value
to the daily vlog.
Figured I'd just talk with you
guys all the stuff that's
on my mind. I think it'll
add some real depth,
real practitionership
to the episode.
Obviously is interesting to see
me hustle but I think I need to
challenge myself
constantly to bring value.
Let's talk about
what's going on.
I think this could be a new cool
new feature about what's going
on in the marketplace.
Today I had a bunch of client
meetings and it's crazy the
biggest companies in the
world are starting to get it.
You could just taste it in the
air and is not just with is not
just with Vayner.
The way they look at Buzzfeed,
the way they look at at
Snapchat, incredible.
It's changing and in the next 5
to 7 years I think we're going
to be in a full transition
period and it's going to be a
remarkable world where many of
you in your 20s and 30s that
intuitively understand
the value and the ROI
of these social media platforms.
Literally guy I was just on
the phone with,
"Social media's taking
over the world."
People are
starting to understand.
I'm trying to get you in
my shot, you're trying
to get your shot.
- [DRock] It happens.
- Oh, come on, DRock.
- [DRock] What?
- DRock, we're in New Jersey.
- [DRock] Are we on the nate?
- What you think about that?
- [DRock] I'm alright.
Did you ever think you'd
be here on your birthday?
Nope.
Oh nice job.
This fucking filter thing
is a big business, man.
I think they got something.
- [DRock] For now, right?
- For a while.
- [DRock] For a while you think?
- Yeah.
I think it's a good
ad product for a year.
Snapchat filters.
I look at Snapchat filters the
way that I looked at hashtags
for Twitter years ago.
It was this new layer on top of
a platform that created context.
When Chris Messina
@FactoryJoe big shout out
Chris Messina created the
hashtag movement on Twitter
it added to the conversation.
You could add this hashtag and
you know and all of a sudden all
these events, all these
conferences, all these places
would create their own hashtag,
but hashtags aren't ownable.
You create a hashtag like #SXSW
or a brand #beautifulskin
well anybody can use it and then
you click it and then people are
spamming all the stuff but
filters, filters on Snapchat.
Snapchat has created context on
their platform in a way that's
ownable and monetizable.
Twitter did make
money on hashtag, DRock.
But Snapchat's going to make it
and everyone of you this summer,
every wedding go to 23
to 29-year-olds or every
27 to 34-year-old wedding you
go to they're going to have a
geofilter a custom geofilter
for that wedding spot and
everybody's going to take all
the pictures and it's going to
say "Karen and
Rick forever 2016."
That's incredible.
Every Bar Mitzvah.
Every Bar Mitzvah in America is
going to have a custom Snapchat
filter in 12 months.
I'm going to be buying custom
filters for business conferences
that I'm not even
going to be at.
And it's going to be like
"yo, it's me say hello."
This is an unbelievably subtle
interesting thing that scales
infinitely there's four filters.
Who knows, they may go up per
thing and so I'm fascinated by
Snapchat filters as a business
model and as a context point
and as an explosion.
In the same way that your dad
now sends you in an emoji,
watch these filters just take
over and watch people
screen shoot and put on their
Facebook and put it on
their Insta and
put it on their Twitter.
Big believer right now.
All in, all chips in on
Snapchat custom filters.
And for three or four of you
designers that are watching
right now brand yourself as a
custom Snapchat filter designer
and I 100%, 100, DRock, percent
predict that somebody will email
me about episode 25 of DailyVee
and how that built their
business because they listened
right now, made a profile,
made a landing playing on
Tumblr or on SquareSpace
or on Wordpress, position
themselves as a custom
Snapchat filter producer.
Writes an article about it.
Maybe wins the lucky SEO game
and literally, literally nine
months from right now
you're making you know
50 filters a day.
You got two people working for
you and you're making $50, $100,
$200, $500 a filter.
And you know I'm right.
- [DRock] Yep.
- And I'm so damn right.
So that's very hot.
I'm excited about that.
MusicAlly picking up steam.
Picking up steam really
winning in junior high.
You guys have heard me, if you
follow me, talk about that.
Just got the bookscan numbers.
That's what's happening today.
I'm going to probably going to
make a posters of this.
I don't know if I can publicly
put this out how many books
I sold in business.
More than everybody else in
the category combined.
Incredible.
Fantasy baseball, super focused
on my fantasy baseball team.
The NCAA tournament,
I had Yale in the upset so
I'm pumped about that.
Doing pretty good there.
Just feeling good, good be home.
Tomorrow I have to fly to
Pittsburgh and back,
so more hustling.
So a lot of that stuff going on.
Sunday night I'm
headed to Dublin.
I don't even know this may air
after I have a funny feeling
this will air, you'll probably
edit this while we're in Dublin
or London, DRock.
I love you Dublin.
(applause)
Thank you for having me.
But I'm excited about my trip
there so I can feel comfortable
in saying that you'll probably
edit actually
you may be filming.
It's going to be interesting.
This one might be delayed but
that's what's going on today.
Little recap of the day.
Oh that was cool light
went out the same time.
(ambient music)